louis barye c'est un bonjour bonjour
monsieur karoutchi candidat pour
l'élection municipale à ducos vous êtes
qualifiés pour le second tour on
rappelle que au premier tour à peine 41
89 % de l'électorat donc ces déplacés
surtout à exprimer des suffrages et à
l'issue de ce premier tour
et bien c'est aurélie n'est là qui est
sorti en tête
ensuite il y à marius narciso et vous
donc en troisième position louis marie
sainte
alors on va pas rappeler parce qu'on n'a
pas énormément de temps on va pas
rappeler les scores des deux chacun
simplement il y à 358 voix qui vous
sépare d'origine et là c'est bien ça
dans la percée finalement accompli par
celle ci au 1er tour vous attendiez-vous
à ce score réalisé par cette candidate
est ce que c'est pas tout de même une
mauvaise surprise pour vous alors pour
être honnête avec vous monsieur kadrige
d'abord je remercie tous les acteurs et
tous les toutes les électrices qui se
sont exprimés en mon nom et au nom de ma
liste unie pour du cos les 1314
électeurs oui effectivement on a un
petit peu surpris parce que tout le
monde attendait notre liste en pole
position mais vous savez j'ai passé le
cours d'un virus et on avait quand même
des dégâts et des gens nous ont exprimé
leur volonté de voir rester chez eux
donc voilà ce petit peu surprenant au vu
du résultat lui est lui-même mais pas le
support rapport au mois lorsque nous
analysons nous analysons la liste
d'émargement alors aurélie dès la 32 6%
marius narciso 27,6 et vous louis marie
sainte 25,7 25 points 78 % des votes du
premier tour
vous êtes en troisième position dans le
triangle du second tour mais avec que 96
voix de moins que le deuxième mario ce
n'est narciso 1
vous voyez que vous voyez que les
résultats sont très serrés et oui
traîtresse réservés et en plus ce
deuxième tour est inédit puisque nous
tous les compteurs sont remis à zéro
donc tout est à refaire pour tout le
monde mais en même temps on peut alors
avec des si vous me direz mais si on
additionne vos scores respectifs à
monsieur narciso et vous
vous peser près de 3000 voix soit 1000
de plus que les suffrages recueillis au
premier tour là le 15 mars par aurait
dîné là alors au plan arithmétique
cela aurait dû peut-être vous inciter à
vous alliez monsieur narciso et vous
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas marché
est-ce que vous avez tant c'est déjà ce
que vous avez même tenté non je n'ai pas
tenté parce que bien sûr je suis pour
les alliances mais je ne suis pas pour
n'importe quelle alliance penser que
déontologiquement et politiquement je ne
n'ai aucune avancée nancy se voulait pas
non plus que je refasse le remake de
2015 vous voyez comment ça a mis la
martinique en dessus le chaos jusqu'à
maintenant
non il n'est pas il n'était pas
acceptable est concevable que je fasse
une alliance avec monsieur narciso pas
du tout d'accord alors ça y est vous
êtes déjà en campagne de la deuxième mi
temps on va dire ça comme ça si on
utilise une métaphore footballistique
alors comment ça se passe en ces temps
de postes confinement liés à l'épidémie
de kovy de louise marie sainte
alors vous savez que cette crise débat
d'abord sanitaire qui est lié au cours
d'un virus m'a conforté dans ma vision
et ma volonté de conduire les destinées
d'une collectivité comme celle de ducos
elle m'a conforté dans l'idée que j'ai
inscrit dans mon contrat de mandature
complètement d'être complètement
disponible pour ma ville et est
responsable il faut avoir une grande
disponibilité ce que j'ai bien vu dans
ceux de ce confinement de ali mais d'un
volontarisme et d'une responsabilité
très forte
loki vraiment il faut être courageux et
prêts et je suis prêt pour cette
bataille je ne m'attaquerai qu'à une
seule fonction une seule c'était déjà
dans mon programme c'est d'être l'air et
le communautaire et on le voit avec
locaux en avion ce sont les mérites et
les plus disponibles les plus attachés à
leur commune qui s'en sont mieux sortis
et c'est ça que je dis je ne briguerai
aucun mandat ni à la cité un autre jeu
serait attaché à ma ville parce que j'ai
vu des problématiques et il faudra au
contact avec lui d'autant qu'il ya du
pain sur la planche ou deux on avait la
redoutable en matière financière
ouais alors donc vous ne vous
consacrerez cas du causse pendant les
six prochaines années vous vous y
engager je m'engage formellement
aujourd'hui encore je le dis je le redis
vous n'irez pas la citer m lannes
absolument pas comme si la ville de
quelle que soit la liste si je suis élu
maire aujourd'hui la fonction de maire
et élu communautaire à l'espace au delà
l'espace puisque scellier c'est
obligatoire ces liens mais aucun devoir
s'arrêter aucun autre mandat je me
battrai avec l'équipe ensemble une
martinique nouvelle pour la cdm
mais je ne serai sur aucune liste c'est
fondamental parce que du cosmos est
archi prioritaire et puis et on a vu le
cours navires us ben il faut être
présent
il faut être prêt et je suis prêt merci
louis marie sainte d'avoir répondu à nos
questions et merci donc à adele le doubs
pour avoir réalisé cette émission
[Musique]